pues después de haberse reunido con los
presidentes del senado y de la cámara de
representantes el presidente italiano
sergio mataré la quiso dirigirse a los
italianos y explicar las razones de esta
decisión dijo que se habían agotado
todas las opciones posibles para no
tener que llegar a esto y que la
situación política actual en el país
pues no no permitía que se creara una
nueva mayoría de gobierno así las cosas
la única salida que vio el presidente
italiano sergio matarla fue la de dar la
palabra a los italianos para que a
través del voto pues expriman se
expresen y logren pues mandar el mensaje
de quien quieren que los gobierne la
fecha de las elecciones ha sido ya
anunciada aquí en italia se votará el
próximo 25 de septiembre y natalia en
medio de la crisis energética y de
inflación en europa la perspectiva de
estas elecciones inquieta a los socios
europeos
así es ya que existe un riesgo real de
que italia caiga en el caos político que
esto pueda afectar a su economía y que
esto cree posiblemente un efecto dominó
en otras economías europeas hay que
saber que italia es la tercera economía
de la zona euro un país con una deuda
colosal y que en europa mario draghi era
percibido como una garantía de seriedad
de estabilidad en particular en lo que
concierne al respeto de los de los
compromisos internacionales del país y
también en la gestión de los fondos
europeos del plan post commit se trata
de una inyección monetaria de 209 mil
millones de euros que irán hacia la
economía italiana y esta crisis cae
también en un muy mal momento para el
país en medio de la pandemia con la
inflación al galope con la guerra en
ucrania y con la preocupación de una
crisis energética que amenaza el país a
partir del próximo invierno
natalia muchas gracias por atendernos y
ampliar nos toda la información desde
roma